Gregorio: Hi, I'm Joe Gregorio.
I work for Google
in developer relations.
And today,
we're gonna be talking
about the Atom
Publishing Protocol.
So let's begin.
This is an intro
to the Atom Publishing Protocol,
and if you want
to know more details,
you can go and read
RFC 5023,
which you should do,
um, if you're interested,
because I'm not gonna cover
all of the details in here.
This is just an overview.
So just as syndication started
with just weblogs,
the Atom Publishing Protocol
was originally designed
just for weblogs.
And that's the motivating
example we're gonna use today.
But just realize that it can
be applied to other areas.
So let's go and look at a feed
in the Atom syndication format.
A feed contains
one entry inside of it
per weblog entry.
And, because it's XML,
it's in a machine-readable
format.
And so
in the aggregation case,
uh, newsreader's gonna go
and pull that feed,
and look for new entries.
And those new entries show up
at the beginning of the feed,
and give you the--
really, the metadata
about that updated entry.
So if you're going
to design a protocol--
and this is what we have with
the Atom Publishing Protocol--
You really need
to do four things.
You would want to be able
to create new entries
on a weblog.
You'd want to be able
to retrieve any new entries,
or old entries.
You would want to update entries
that already exist.
And lastly,
you would want
to delete entries out.
So if you look
at syndication right now,
as far
as building a protocol,
really, we already
have retrieve done.
Right, 'cause I can go to
the URI where that feed lives,
do a get,
and get the latest things.
Here's the fundamental idea
of the Atom Publishing Protocol,
and that is any changes
you would make to a feed
are gonna be reflected
in the weblog.
Uh, for various reasons, though,
you probably don't want
to use the same exact feed
that you would put
into an aggregator
as you would
for editing.
You may have drafts
that you're working on,
and you would want those drafts
to be available for you to edit,
but you really don't want
those going out
before they're allowed
to be seen in the public.
So we're
gonna differentiate.
There's going to be, uh,
the aggregation feed,
and what we're gonna
be talking about today
is the collection feed.
We have retrieve.
We're already basically
a quarter of the way done
with the Atom Publishing
Protocol.
We can retrieve.
How about creating?
What--what would we do
to create?
Well, in the Atom
Publishing Protocol,
it's the simplest thing
you could possibly think of.
We take an Atom entry,
and we post it to the URI
of the collection feed.
That's just an entry.
There's no surrounding
feed element around it.
So post that,
and that gets added
to the feed.
Like we said before,
this change to the feed
will also get reflected
in the weblog.
All right, so we're,
in essence,
halfway done with
the Atom Publishing Protocol.
So we have
Create and Retrieve,
and the other two parts
are Update and Delete.
So let's go back and look
at that entry that was added
to the collection feed.
When you create
a new entry,
the server will add
some other elements
to that entry.
In this case,
what you're seeing here
is the edit URI,
and every entry that
gets created will have it.
and that's the URI
by which you're going to update,
delete,
and retrieve that entry.
So let's cover
the simplest case first,
which is DELETE.
This is actually just--
You're going to send
a simple HTTP delete message
to the URI
of that entry.
And that's it.
There's no body
that goes along in that request.
Just a DELETE.
Once that DELETE
gets received by the server,
that entry gets removed
from the feed.
And like we said before,
That gets reflected
in the weblog.
That weblog entry
goes away.
Okay, so we've got
Create, Retrieve, and Delete.
The last thing
we need is Update.
So at that edit URI,
you can actually
do a GET,
and get
the full entry.
And you will need to do that,
because according
to the publishing protocol
specification,
the entry that sits
in the collection
may not be
the full entry.
It might be abbreviated
in order to keep bandwidth down.
So I can go
to that edit URI,
do a GET,
and get the full representation.
Now, if I wanted
to update what was going on,
I could actually modify
that entry on my client,
and then put it back
to that exact same URI.
And so in this case,
I have updated the title.
I do a PUT, and now
that entry will be updated.
And that'll get reflected
in the feed,
and on the weblog.
So we're done.
We've covered
all four parts
of what you would want
out of a publishing protocol.
Creating, retrieving,
updating and deleting entries.
Well, we're at least done
as far as text is concerned.
What about media?
What if I wanted to add
an image or a sound or video?
How do you do that
in the Atom Publishing Protocol?
Really, it's the--
Again, the simplest possible
thing you could imagine.
We take your media,
and you send that
in an HTTP post request,
again, to the same exact
collection URI.
That adds it to there.
Media is slightly different,
in that when I post media,
I actually create
two distinct resources.
I'm gonna create
a resource with the URI
that is the actual
media itself,
like the image.
And then,
there's going to be
what's called
a "media link entry."
That's the metadata
about the picture.
The title,
the time it was posted, etc.
We can see
those two resources
when we look
at the media link entry
that gets added
to the collection.
The edit link points,
like I said,
to the media link entry,
and you can
manipulate that
just like we did previously
with entries.
I can do a GET on that,
to get the entry,
I can to a PUT on it
to update it,
and I can send it a DELETE
to remove it.
And then there's
the edit media link.
That supports
GET and PUT.
So if I wanted
to update that image,
I would change the image,
and put the image--
and that's an HTTP PUT--
to the edit media URI.
If I wanted to update
the title of that image,
I would update--change
the media link entry,
and put that entry--
HTTP PUT--
to the edit URI.
And, like I said before,
if you wanted
to remove that media,
you would send a DELETE.
Again, no body,
just send a DELETE
to the edit URI.
Now, this is actually
a slight distinction.
That's the way you end up
removing the metadata
about the image,
and the image itself.
You only need
to send one delete,
and that'll
remove both of them.
So in the examples
we've done so far,
I've assumed that
there's just one collection,
and we're adding
our entries
and our media
to that same collection.
That might not
actually be the case.
That might actually be
a little difficult to organize.
So we may actually
break it down
into multiple collections.
There may be
a collection for entries,
and then there may
be a collection
for all of your images.
Or there may be
a link blog.
You can break things down
that way.
So how do you discover
which collections are available?
That's where the service
document comes into play.
That contains information
about all of the collections
that a service supports.
So if you look
at a service document,
you'll see that there
are collections grouped together
into workspaces.
Um, and now here,
we're looking
at a collection
that just takes entries.
And right there,
in that HREF,
that is the URI
for our collection.
Now we know
what to do with that.
We could post to that
to add new things
to that collection.
There's actually two collections
in this service document,
and the second one
is a media collection.
And those accept elements
tell you the types of media
that you are allowed
to post
to that collection.
In this case, it can accept
JPEGs, PNGs and GIFs.
Okay, so that finishes
our overview
of the Atom
Publishing Protocol.
If you want to learn more,
you can always read RFC 4287,
which is the internet standard
for the Atom Syndication Format.
You can also read RFC 5023,
which is the IETF standard for
the Atom Publishing Protocol.
In addition, a good video
to follow this one
is Jeff Fisher's
"Intro to Google Data,"
which is available also
on YouTube.
Uh, that covers
how Google has implemented
some of these standards.
And finally, you can always go
to code.google.com/apis/gdata,
which covers
all of the documentation
for Google's APIs.
Thanks, and have fun.